what is a bland Oldman plot the Bland
Oldman plot is a graphical method to
compare two measurements in a sense a
bland Alman plot is a scatter plot where
the differences between two measurements
are plotted against their averages this
helps to visualize the degree of
agreement between two rers and to
identify any systematic bias let's look
at an example let's say we're doing
research in the field of blood glucose
measurement and we want to compare two
blood glucose meters gluco classic and
glucon new to do this we collect data
from 10 patients who have measured the
BL glucose using both meters to create a
bland Oldman plot the first step is to
calculate the difference of the
respective pairs 105 minus 100 equal 5
155 - 150 is also 5 85 - 82 = 3 and so
on and then we need to calculate the
mean of the paired values 105 + 100 ided
2 is
102.5 155 + 150 / 2 is
152.5 and so so on so now we have for
each pair the difference between rer one
and rer 2 and for each pair the mean of
rer 1 and rer 2 with these two values we
can now start drawing the plant Oldman
plot so let's just draw an X and A Y AIS
on the Y AIS we plot the difference
between the two values and on the xaxis
we plot the mean value of each pair now
we can add add all the values we enter
the first point with a mean value of
102.5 and a difference of five the
second point is entered for a mean value
of
152.5 and also a difference of five we
now do this for all other
values now we can calculate the mean of
the differences and plot it on a PL
Oldman plot we simply add up all the
differences and divide by 10
this results in
3.7 that is what we call the bias on
average greater 1 measures 3.7 more than
Raa 2 next we can calculate the standard
deviation of the differences the
standard deviation results in
1.25 with the standard deviation we can
calculate the 95% confidence interval to
do this we simply calculate the mean
plus and minus
1.96 times the standard deviation so we
can calculate the upper limit with
3.7 +
1.96 *
1.25 which is
6.25 and the lower limit was 3.7 -
1.96 *
1.25 which is
1.25 this range is also called limits of
agreement
amazing we have created a bland Oldman
plot but how can we interpret a bland
Oldman plot let's take a closer look at
the bias analysis the scatter analysis
and the limits of agreement bias
analysis if the mean difference bias is
close to zero and most data points are
scattered closely around this mean
without any specific Trend it suggests
that glucon new provides readings very
similar to gluc Classic a mean
difference drifting away from zero
signals systematic bias in our example
it looks like we have a small bias of
3.7 scatter analysis random scatter is a
positive sign indicating consistent
differences across measurement
magnitudes however patterns like
funneling could indicate proportional
biases or
heteroscedasticity for example the
devices might agree more when glucose
levels are in a low and medium range but
disagree at high levels limits of
agreement the limits of agreement give
the 95% confidence interval of the
differences between the measurements
they are crucial for understanding the
variability of the differences if you
like you can G create a bland Oldman
plot for free online using datab just go
to data.net and copy your own data into
this table then click on either
descriptive or charts then simply select
your two metric variables if you now
scroll down you will be presented with
many charts that could be suitable for
the data including the Bland Oldman plot
thanks for watching and I hope you
enjoyed the video
video